hello everyone and welcome to some very
weird news from the Chess World it's not
actually new news it's actually news
from 2021 I've just never heard of it uh
it's uh regarding the video World
University women's online rapid
Championship now that's quite the title
but it has very little to do with the
actual story uh except that it was
played uh in that event and it features
uh Julia osma she's an international
master and the women's Grandmaster from
Ukraine and she scored very nicely in
this tournament she scored four and a
half out of five in the finals there
were first there were preliminaries and
then uh whoever qualified goes into the
final scene she scored four and a half
out of five in the finals so which is
which is quite spectacular she won a
full point ahead of the competition but
after the competition some three days
after she already won it and everyone
proclaimed her the winner she was
disqualified for uh as it as it would
seem for for cheating on the event now
they didn't specify how or why or uh who
who uh there was the the cheating
committee and they had to vote was the
evidence enough to disqualify her from
the tournament and out of four people
two voted yes one voted no and one was
abstained and now there is quite a uh a
lot about this story I will put an
article by Peter Dodgers fortress.com
first link in the description below you
can check it out uh but uh yeah I
decided to show you one of the games and
it's such a such a weird thing because
it's a very short game and both um Julie
osmack and her opponent for this game
all gabadelka Bella Russian
International Master yeah both of them
uh oh no another International Master
she's a women's Grandmaster I believe uh
let me just check real quickly
uh yeah she's a she's a women
Grandmaster
they they both missed quite a lot and
it's quite an interesting game it's a
it's a nice game but nothing that would
be suspicious for for any reason and
also she is the 2017 Ukraine Women's
Champion here you can see her with the
with the Grand Master Natalia tsukola
and the women's Grandmaster and the
international master all gababi so she
won at first place um ahead of them and
some other very very strong players now
what's interesting is how I got to this
story uh as usual by browsing the
internet now here you can see a very
very short conversation uh not that
that's just a larger board but basically
affiliate director General Emil sutovsky
I posted on Twitter today one thing most
people are missing completely when a
person is publicly accused of cheating
by fide or platforms the statistical
probability is not like 51 not 75 not
even 99 percent it is 99.999 and more
depending on the standard of proof
fide's standard of proof is the highest
so naturally I started to start some
trouble by by tweeting something I asked
are you uh accusing someone of cheating
to which Emily replied it happened more
than once in past Neiman case is
reviewed and fide does not jump to the
conclusions but for the ongoing debate
it is important to understand what is
considered to be a standard of a
statistical evidence now a gentleman
with a profile photo of Nikola Tesla
wrote something and then how I came to
this article chest 24 someone who was
running the account at the time this was
tweeted said this case in a fide event
was 99.999 and more uh referring to the
to the case that I will now present
considering it's reported the fair play
committee was split two to one with the
abstention or whether to ban the player
now Emil replies that was a totally
different case it was not reviewed by
the fair play commission but just a fair
plane a fair play tournament panel which
could take a sanction for a particular
tournament only the decision was based
not only on statistical data but also on
circumstantial evidence now like I said
do check out the story by uh by Peter
Dodgers it it's it's quite a big one and
further analysis was done regarding all
of the games of the tournament and not a
lot was fun because they said that
basically they have to meet only one of
the criteria in order for their decision
to stand such as well there are many
ideas but after the tournament uh
they've um uh had a separate
investigation which had meetings with
the student meetings with all fair play
panel members additional meetings that
deemed useful Grandmaster analysis of
moves played by the student including
time spent comparison of moves played by
the student with engine recommendations
analysis of statistical evidence of the
platform analysis of statistical
evidence of an external expert analysis
of video evidence and Analysis of audio
evidence now all of this was approved
negative and there weren't really any
reasons for the decision to stand but
fide on the on their website said that
their their decision stands and that's
just it now if you guys know more about
the story of this one in 2021 I haven't
found any sources regarding the matter
but I've decided to show you one game
and it's a it's a real really an
interesting one so here she faces Julia
all my osmack faces Olga badelka uh
let's uh check it out so Julia has the
white pieces and opens with D4 we have
D5 Pawn to C4 and the D captures on C4
accepting the Queen's Gambit with E3
going after the pawn and I'll just
Knight to F6 this is very standard stuff
the old variation on the Queen's Gambit
the bishop captures on C4 E6 and not
Knight to F3 we have Ponte A6 preparing
to chase the bishop with B5 and here uh
uh Julia just castles with Pawn to see
five striking against the center B3 and
now Knight the C6 with Bishop to beat
you and not Pawn to B5 so this is all
very standard stuff and considered the
main line of the classical Queens Gambit
accepted Bishop back to EQ with Bishop
to B7 and now Pawn to A4 again nothing
new here all of this has been played
before upon the B4 and now Knight beat
the D2 C captures on D4 just uh grabbing
in the center here we have a capture
Fest captures captures captures and
Bishop to E7 Olga just there's the
castle here and now there are some games
where Bishop to F3 was played here and
Julia first goes for Knight the C4
before going for Bishop to F3 we have
castles and now Bishop to F3 and there
there are some games that reach this
position for example Knight the E4 is a
known move uh but uh here we have Bishop
to D5 and it is now as of move 15 that
we have a completely new game and the
bishop to D5 is sort of a sub-optimal
move that allows Yulia to fully take
advantage of the situation as white has
control over the B6 square and the
Knight can create a permanent Outpost
there by pushing the pawn to A5 so
Knight to B6 as this comes with Tempo
Rook the B8 and now just Pawn to A5 now
this Knight is beautifully placed here
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Knight to D5 uh or preparing to
eliminate the Knight here now Rook F to
D1 and the Knight captures and B6 and
okay here you might expect Bishop
captures but capturing with the pawn is
actually better as it creates it's a
passport immediately and also the A6
spawn is now hanging and here we have
Queen to E8
now how do you how do you play this
position well uh you would probably try
and take advantage of this situation by
grabbing the A6 pawn and it's very hard
to uh to see why why not play this but
here we have Queen to G4 first going for
checkmate saying okay I can always
capture on A6 we have Ponta G6 not
blocking Checkmate and Rook captures an
A6 capturing an A6 was
um much much better and much stronger
recommendation by the engine than just
going for this uh Checkmate threat we
have Queen to B5 now attacking The Rook
here and just Rook D to A1 doubling up
on the a file we have Queen to D5 now
and here comes Quinta F4 another very
interesting situation is Queen to F3 is
considered just winning by the engine
but here we have Queen to F4 and now
Bishop to D6 challenging the queen uh we
have Queen to F6 not just threatening
Checkmate and of course Pawn to E5
that's the whole point uh because if not
for E5 there's no a way to defend
Checkmate and now it seems that Olga was
able to defend this but there is a
problem there is this Rook 6 to A5 move
that's the only move that allows white
to to play for Advantage okay you could
maybe move the best of the back but Rook
to A5 just makes more sense as it goes
after the E5 pawn and now the only way
for black to play this is to play Queen
to E6 and offer a queen trade however in
the game Queen captures and B3 was
played and now White's position is
completely winning if Julia finds this
uh is the only winning move but it's um
not that difficult to spot so just for
comparison feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning idea
for iulia while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh removing the
obstacle on E5 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course a rook captures an E5 yeah this
was played in the game and now uh
there's really nothing for you to do so
congratulations to everyone who found
this point is that if the Rook is
accepted then Bishop captures and there
is no defense against Checkmate so in
the game after Rook captures an E5 Rook
the A8 was played challenging The Rook
honey one uh but now just the again the
simple Rook ETA A5 and it was in this
position that Olga badelka resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here now The Rook is being
threatened and also Checkmate is being
threatened and there is no way to stop
uh well basically either uh whatever you
play Just Queen G7 will be Checkmate so
it's really not a game that requires any
I mean how did white win black made a
few sub-optimal moves and they weren't
really moves that it it was very hard to
take advantage of I'm sure a lot of you
guys when you have pause the video you
have found it like the only the only
tricky move in the in the game was Rook
K5 uh but it's not all that tricky I
mean you just attack the queen and the
E5 Pawn is hanging now now a lot of
other people discussed this on Twitter
again something that I've missed I have
no idea why because I do check stuff uh
specifically chess stuff on Twitter for
example here you have Ruslan palomario
former Fida world champion he said that
I watched the games of Yulia osmack from
defeated World online chess University
championship and can claim 110 that I
didn't find any evidence of cheating uh
uh hashtag Justice for rosma hashtag
Fairplay matters hashtag we are awesome
I've missed all of this I have no idea
how and even here you can see yeah Susan
Polgar says that this is what I really
do not understand so if one is not
accused of cheating then why is the
score erased and how is it possible that
the players can defend themselves very
confusing so that's something that's
also very interesting the the uh sort of
the the fair play committee or as Emil
stated the fair play panel never
actually accused her of cheating they
just decided to erase all of her games
based on some evidence although I don't
think it was ever provided what evidence
and yeah it is just weird and not only
not only her they disqualified like 20
other players as well so as the uh the
the the the Costa niman Saga is also
currently being investigated by fide I I
hope that they will you know give more
due diligence than they did in this case
uh Julia even requested
um that she be put on a lie detector
something that everyone's been joking
around you know just put put hands on a
lie detector and you know just see you
know if you will say yes or no I mean it
doesn't really matter if the lie
detector works or not but she requested
it for herself and they were not
interested in uh such uh such an
adventure so I have no idea how this
Saga Ended as it was in 2021 a lot has
been happening in the world and in
Ukraine and you know just you know covet
stuff so so I don't know if this has
been addressed as at all since then but
yeah just thought you guys might might
have missed this as I have also missed
this but yeah very nice game just a very
clean win by white but nothing uh I mean
absolutely nothing out of your ordinary
Happening Here uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and that
you've uh well uh heard a story that you
haven't heard before the entire article
by Peter doors is in the description
below do check it out if you can dig up
some more on this maybe they've um you
know they had something additional I
just wasn't able to find it uh do share
so everyone else can learn a bit as well
so yeah that's the game and a little bit
of additional info hope you guys enjoyed
that I would like to thank ante venma eh
music uh Jose Palacio Chris Malin and GJ
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
curvature of everything that's happening
in the Chess World and uh checking it up
on your recommendations which I always
appreciate so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day